Going into this show I thought it could have
some potential, but I ended up leaving it mostly
disappointed and wanting more. Echo is kind of a
fresh slate character that I didn’t know anything
about, so I thought this could be an interesting
mini-series. Especially since one of the writers
from Better Call Saul was working on the show and
Marvel was going to finally dive into something
that was more mature. But if anything, I feel
like the R-rated marketing campaign was more
of a way to get people’s attention because it
was still pretty PG-13. And the writing was
nothing special. Which going into the first
major shortfall is that Echo as a miniseries
is very underdeveloped. The creators try to do a
lot with a pretty short runtime because the show
is only 3 hours once you subtract the opening
intros and end-credits. So in this time they
try to tackle a family drama with a handful of
characters, an entire backstory and re-cap of
Hawkeye that spans the first episode, a more
detailed relationship between Maya and Fisk,
this native american power origin, and then the
entire war/conflict between Maya and Fisk. I’ve
seen people say that the show should have been
cut down to like 2 hours, but I’d actually argue
the opposite. Echo needed a much longer runtime to
properly develop all of these different aspects of
the show. Because by being stretched so thin and
trying to cover so much, it in turn isn’t able
to properly build-up these elements and pay them
off in a satisfying manner. Like as an example,
Maya gets ripped away from most of her family as
a child and then she returns to her hometown. This
I think is an interesting dynamic to build upon
relationships, but the show is preoccupied with
so much that the character work never hits a
satisfying depth. And you probably wouldn’t
be expecting a family drama out of Echo, but
I honestly found some of it compelling. Mainly
because the first episode of the show makes you
sympathize and care about Maya and you want her
to rekindle her past relationships and thus become
happier in life. The parallel between Fisk being a
manipulative figure and a toxic influence versus
her Native American family that wants to truly
love her I thought was pretty good. Along with
the acting requiring more physicality and facial
expressions since Maya was deaf and characters
interacting with her had to use sign language.
If anything, I thought the whole action side of
the show was very underwhelming and was in general
unimaginative. This may be a major turn off for
most of you because Marvel as a brand is supposed
to be an exciting and action packed adventure,
but that isn’t what Echo is. They try to make
it a more grounded drama series with a strong
native american perspective. There’s action here,
but it’s definitely not the selling point of
the series. Which I think is kind of refreshing,
but again, since the series is so short and is
stretched so thin, I don’t think it’s able to
hit a high enough quality to really be worth the
time. Like if you really wanted a great recent
native american story then go watch Killers of
the Flower Moon. It’s basically the same runtime
and that movie is way better. To not purely bash
the show, I think the performances in Echo are
pretty solid and it’s mostly unfortunate that the
writers couldn’t give these characters more scenes
to flesh out their dynamics. Hell, Maya’s best
friend has like one quick and awkward scene with
Maya and she doesn’t get any kind of emotional
reconnection with Maya in the end. It feels
so rushed and unfulfilling as a dramatic story
that it makes me wonder if the writer actually
wrote it this way, or if they were pressured
by the producers to make the story shorter,
or if there were some budgetary issues. Like
the premise I think is pretty solid and should
allow for a great story and with more time and
episodes, I assume that could have been the case.
Now going into the other more inferior half of the
show in my opinion, let’s talk about the Fisk and
overall war plotline. There’s a lot that annoys me
and first, let’s discuss the relationship between
Fisk and Maya because it largely feels like a
retcon. You’re telling me that this character
who Fisk has been raising, is very close to him,
and is a deadly fighter that he regularly uses
never went up against Daredevil during his show? I
know Echo as an IP wasn’t even on Netflix’s radar
when they were making Daredevil, but supplanting
her into that narrative when it doesn’t make any
sense I think is pretty jarring. Like Fisk was
on the ropes fighting for his life using all of
his assets during that show and apparently Maya
was never used. She’s just been hiding in the
background until now. So that’s kind of an aspect
that you have to accept about the story because
the writers want to make Fisk an integral part of
Maya’s life. When that was never set up before.
From here, the relationship between Maya and Fisk
feels rather inconsistent and confuses me. At
the end of Hawkeye, she flat-out murders Fisk by
shooting him in the face and I was like wow what
an underwhelming way to end such a magnificent
villain in Daredevil. And then after the show
they said Fisk would return in Echo and was like
Huhhh? I was eagerly awaiting the explanation as
to how Fisk would survive a gunshot wound to
the head and apparently all they did was slap
a bandage onto his eye like Phil Swift plugging a
hole of water with Flex tape. It’s such a joke of
a way to handle this character and why would
you ever write it to where Fisk gets shot in
the head and returns. That completely undercuts
any stakes and weight for death scenes because
if Fisk can survive a headshot wound then I’m not
going to be concerned about his well-being in the
future. It’s just a mind-boggling writing choice
that feels the same as Sabine getting skewered by
a lightsaber. But at least she didn’t sustain a
critical injury where her brain was. From here,
most of the confrontations between Fisk and Maya
are him approaching her with no defenses as she
has a gun trained on him. Which seems confusing
to me because if she was so eager to kill him
then why not do so again. I know Fisk is trying
to manipulate her, but most of their shared scenes
together he fails to do so and she for some reason
chooses to not kill him. Despite her not really
changing much since her first attempt at trying
to take his life. She does change by the end of
the show and without going into spoilers she has a
different solution to Fisk as a problem which just
felt really weird. It has to do with her entire
power which I also thought wasn’t explained that
much. They left it relatively vague and I’m not
sure if that was their intention because it seems
to give her multiple unrelated powers. But I
feel like going into that would be a spoiler,
so I won’t do that. Overall, the dynamic between
Fisk and Maya was not convincing because the
writers primarily tell us that they have this
strong bond without really establishing it.
Like why is Fisk so obsessed with Maya when
he has so much more on his plate? What about
her does he love so much? Why is he going so far
out of his way to be this father figure and raise
her? The only real motivation they establish
is that Fisk was mostly using her as a weapon,
but Fisk has plenty of those. And why would he
risk killing her father when there’s a possibility
she could find out. To me, it all comes across as
forcing Maya and Fisk together to try and make an
interesting story without it seeming realistic.
Especially since she’s non-existent in Daredevil.
Which I could honestly forgive that if they
actually dedicated more time to establishing her
past with Fisk and answering all those questions,
but again, that means more time for telling this
story. Leading back to the issue of Echo largely
being underdeveloped. Also within this half of the
show we have the action side of things. I’ve seen
some people say that they really liked it, but to
me, I thought it was pretty flawed. It has some
great choreography, however, I think it’s dragged
down by some of its cinematography and editing.
The first action scene with Daredevil uses the
notorious fake oner that if done poorly can be
really distracting and can also be a detriment
to the presentation of the action. Because what’s
even the point of faking a oner if you’re just
going to wipe the camera and hide cuts every 3
seconds. It’s painfully obvious and since they
are trying to create one continuous shot, it leads
to some moments being awkwardly framed. There have
been some incredible examples of fake oners like
in Guardians of the Galaxy 3 where the hidden cuts
aren’t as jarring and the action is always framed
in a great way. Or you have Daredevil where they
actually do real oners. So this action scene while
it does have some great choreography, I think is
filmed in a bad way. Then for another fight
scene, the editing was very sporadic and fast
paced making the edit overly jarring. That and
they would also try to draw parallels to Maya’s
Native American past by using quick cutaways of
her ancestors fighting. Which makes the edit even
more chaotic and annoying. It’s also really
sad because every now and then they’ll have a
wide shot longer take showing the action, meaning
that this is the level they could be operating on,
but then they butcher it with a bunch of quick
unnecessary cuts. And the editor even utilizes
jump cuts for this one shot. There’s just so many
editing choices that don’t feel well-suited for
the action. Then for an action scene at night,
the editor raised the brightness so much to
the point that the black levels looked terrible.
Like why would you even bother making this scene
outside at night if you were going to butcher
the look of your scene. Not to mention that this
action scene was overall very unimaginative and
boring. It was just Maya running across a train,
planting something, and then she jumps off. Like
the writers really couldn’t come up with anything
more interesting or engaging? Also in these action
scenes, they come across as having barely any
impact or consequences because Maya always comes
away unscathed. She deadass throws her body off
of a train and gets rocked by a truck that then
hard brakes and she’s A OK. She even has this
massive bullet wound in the side of her torso that
gets sowed up and then literally the scene after
this she climbs an entire water tower. Like Maya
as a character sustains no physical punishments
that made a show like Daredevil feel so raw and
real. The only thing of consequence that happens
to Maya is that her prosthetic leg gets crushed,
but it instantly gets replaced. The fight scenes
in Daredevil however were deeply investing because
we knew that Matt Murdoch was always in danger
because he would sustain life threatening
injuries. But in Echo? The writers couldn’t
be bothered with doing this because I guess they
don’t have enough time to do so. So that in turn
makes the action feel weightless. They just throw
some flashy action around and move on instantly
as if nothing happened. Another main reason why
Daredevil was so great is that they balanced the
action downtime with deep and personal character
development. This is what Echo should have been,
and wasn’t. There’s only like a few action scenes
and maybe a couple emotional dialogue scenes.
Also, Maya literally shows up to her hometown
and jeopardizes everyone’s safety by bringing
about a war because of her own personal vendetta.
She’s risking the lives of her entire family every
step of the way and she’s even called out on
this, but this entire notion is dropped by the
end of the show and is not explored again. There
are basically no consequences for her actions.
They set up like six characters in her family
and none of them die. Which I don’t need there
to be character deaths, but instead tangible
consequences. This in turn makes the story
lack depth because the writers are acting like
this critical conflict doesn’t exist. Instead,
they should be exploring this considerably and
even have Maya as a character confront the fact
that what she’s doing is wrong. Thus changing
and evolving her as a character. And the way
she changes is through her rekindling her love
for her true family. Then the general plot for
the overall war if you can even call it that
is so stereotypical and nothing happens in the
story that is remotely interesting. Maya just
attacks a compound and Fisk realiates briefly
and that’s basically it in terms of the plot.
There’s not a single surprise in the entire
story and it’s probably one of the most generic
plots that Marvel ever created. Along with a lot
of scenes being filled with dumb moments like
Maya getting captured and one of her kidnappers
kindly giving back her foot, which she uses to
get out. Maya also randomly becomes Macgiver in
one scene and makes this complicated invention
despite this skill never being established,
or Fisk conveniently calling off his men
right before they’re about to kill Maya.
And heyyy, these all take place in one episode.
So this entire war aspect of the story isn’t just
dull, but it’s also pretty dumb. That’s why I’d
say the actual meat of this story is the family
drama which will inherently disappoint some
people and turn others away. It does have some
strong moments like the scene between Maya and her
grandmother which was infused with an endearing
emotional connection, but these moments are few
and far between and aren’t enough to redeem the
utter mediocrity of Echo. I don’t think Echo as a
show is as bad as Secret Invasion, but I wouldn’t
be surprised if it gets overrated by Marvel fans
purely because it isn’t an abomination. From my
perspective, I don’t think this show is worth the
time because there’s so many other better shows
and movies to watch. Thank you for watching and if
you want to see more of my ratings since I don’t
do videos on everything I watch then check out my
Letterboxd. And my Patreon and discord links are
in the description. Have a great day and let me
know what you thought about Echo in the comments.